- I was at my
parents this weekend,
my dad and I talked about
how we were making $35,000 a
year in the prime of
when I built Wine Library.
We made $35,000 a year.
Every dollar just
went into building it.
(triumphant rock music)
What if I told you
this was the
last Monday
morning of your life?
- [Vernon] Just go
all-in and go all-in really.
That's not like his words
but if you go and do it, do it.
You know what I'm saying?
He keeps it straight up
with me, he keeps it real.
You know what I'm saying?
If my ideas or any of our
ideas aren't good enough,
he's gonna let us know.
You know what I'm saying?
I think what me and
Akeem got going on,
we're going to do something
big these next few months,
few years so it's
going to be good.
- Like, what's my
advice of making money?
- [Vernon] Yeah, exactly.
- [Gary] Cool.
- [Vernon] Just your
advice and if you don't mind--
- [Gary] Yeah.
- take notes on my iPhone.
Do you want to record it?
So you can listen,
you know what I mean?
- Yes, absolutely.
- [Gary] Think that's a
smart move in general.
I think people need to
record meetings more often.
- [Vernon] Yeah, I know.
I really wanted to learn how
to make money on the offseason
'cause being in Canada we only
get paid during the season
I just wanted to
really pick his mind,
pick his brain and
see what I can do,
anything I can do on the side
and he really helped me out with
giving me some good tips.
I recorded our conversation.
- I think that there's a couple
ways to think
about making money.
You can make money as an
entrepreneur and businessperson,
which I've done, you know you
build and you sell stuff and
you start a business.
There's also you've got enough
just enough level of fame to be
you and make money.
What does that mean?
That means, and we can help
you with this a little bit,
can you get paid $2,000 to
give a talk in the Northwest?
That's where your
brand most lives, right?
I think what you do with
Akeem like documenting,
creating content is,
content is the absolute
gateway to opportunity.
You know you can
make one video that,
DRock I don't know if you're
listening to this 'cause this
might be scratching.
I don't know how I clipped it.
Yeah, so you may
want to do that.
- And then also went to
a Jets game yesterday,
my first NFL game ever.
Jets and Patriots,
sorry Jets fans.
Your team lost, but man, it was
a good game and had a good time
with my guy GaryVee.
Appreciate you brother and
AJ and the rest of the guys.
- Are you guys first cousins?
- No, we're really,
really close friends.
- Got it.
- We've known each
other since we were five,
four years old.
- Adopted cousins.
- Yeah.
- We were living with
each other in college.
- [Gary] Understood.
- [Vernon] We've been
together for a long time.
- [Tyler B] How'd you get
involved with this guy?
- Vernon?
- [Tyler B] Yeah.
- Oh, we grew up since
we were little kids. You know?
Jackie Robinson Park,
we go back.
- [Gary] Is this uncle the
same way or is this actually
somebody's uncle?
- Same way.
(group laughter)
Yeah, man,
listen I love it. I love it.
I mean 100% that's
the way to do it.
- Just, we go back high school--
- [Vernon] It's family.
- Pop Warner football,
middle school,
you know, college.
Actually he went to Oregon and
I went to Oregon State and the
Beavers we just won the
Civil War in the first time in
like since 2007 so, you know,
all my Beaver fans out there
watching this know we did it.
You guys did it, baby.
You guys, did it.
- Alright, let's keep
talking about this.
We're gonna start
working on the talk.
working on your website.
I'm gonna take a look at that.
Let me give some,
yeah, I'm gonna keep this.
Let me have a few
minutes on this and
we'll take it from there.
Good to see you, man.
- [Vernon] My dog,
I appreciate it, man.
- Really impressive, my man.
- [Man] See you tomorrow.
- [Akeem] So we're
heading back to California,
I'm heading back to
California today so.
- Email. Email. Alright?
Akeem, a real pleasure
man, real impressed.
- Can we get a selfie?
- [Gary] Yeah, of course.
Yeah.
I know we've been moving in a
ton on them but it's worth it.
- [DRock] Not
allowed to film this?
- Nope.
- [Tyler] Marcus is
downstairs in the lobby.
- Cool. Okay.
It's good to see you, DRock.
How was your Asia trip?
- [DRock] It was fabulous.
- Good. That's my post game.
Yes, yes, I drive.
Just so you know, my bit to
Stephen Ross put a link to it.
They'll understand. See you.
("Dirty Money" by MadReal)
DRock?
- [DRock] Yeah?
- I think...
How are you, brother?
- Good, how are you?
- Gary, Chris.
- [Gary] Chris, such a pleasure.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] How are things?
- Sky's okay.
- [Gary] Just okay?
- Yeah.
- [Roger] Gary, how are you?
- I am super well.
- [Roger] Jets loss last night?
- No, yesterday was
actually perfect. Seriously.
See you guys.
- See you, Roger.
We went to high school together.
- [Gary] Get out.
- [Chris] He's--
- He's the best.
- [Chris] the best.
- The best.
- [Chris] You guys,
it's popping in here.
- Yeah, we're a, you
know, you put 500
27, 29-year-olds together and
you get some serious energy.
- [Chris] It's awesome.
I'm sitting in the
lobby and people are
bustling through like crazy.
- [Gary] You probably
feel this too, right?
It's unbelievable how much an
organization will actually take
the exact personality
of its leader.
- [Chris] Yeah.
- It's a stunning
misunderstanding.
If your company sucks,
your leader sucks.
That's just real because
she or he is in charge.
They can get rid of
all the bad stuff.
I hate when
leaders are like,
"Oh, it's Rick's fault."
I'm like, "You
hired Rick, fucker."
You know?
- [Chris] Tell me about it.
- Yeah.
Andy?
Video, video,
video, video, video,
video, video, video.
1.7 million on the 61 seconds.
- What's the best way--
- To get me to make captions?
'Cause that's
what's holding us up?
No? Oh?
- I'm organizing them to get the
BSUs and wallpapers but then you
pick the ones that you want and
so I'm like let's
hold on to those.
So I just pinged
you 11 videos--
- Yeah.
- that I think are good, that
are diverse enough that they can
start working on micro
and things to map to.
- Got it. Okay.
- Versus--
- I trust you on that.
Let them go on that.
- Okay.
So I can text it to you again.
- You need copy for Facebook.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Another thing, do you
think I'm right about not
putting too many, if I'm
gonna build up DailyVee,
I think too much content is
not gonna make people want to be
subscribed so I think
what we should do...
- [DRock] We were
talking about that.
- On YouTube?
- We also talked about Gary
talking to the camera a lot.
- Yeah, there's a
bunch of different things.
(laughs) We talk
about everything a lot.
Do you think that if we're
making this commitment to
DailyVee that we
should maybe only
put two videos a day max?
And what we do is then use--
- I think we can get
away with two to three,
one of them always
being DailyVee so--
- I want to go two.
I believe I'm right about this.
- One being DailyVee?
- One being DailyVee,
one being something else.
We have to do that.
- Yeah.
- We should always
do one of those--
- Every day.
- [Gary] Every day.
- [Man] 'Sup my dude?
- [Gary] All good stuff, man.
How are you?
- [Man] Can't believe this.
- Oh, you were here
when we moved here, no?
- [Man] No!
- Jesus.
- Some of the guys, man.
How much time do
you spend in LA?
- A ton.
- LA's good for
tacos, vinyl records.
- Weather.
- Weather and vintage clothing.
- Yeah.
- The people just different.
- 100%. Especially for me.
I'm like hustle for
New York so LA feels like...
- You get it.
- But, but, the
weather can seduce you.
- It can.
- The weather can trick you.
- Don't let the
weather trick you.
- We have some great nights.
- The snow.
- Yeah, after a snowstorm.
- Linds, I need to talk
to you about don't let me
forget about (censored).
- [Linds] Okay.
Most definitely.
- Yeah. It was really good.
'Sup Alex?
- [Linds] Cool.
- [Alex] What's going on?
- How are you?
- [Alex] I'll guess
I'll kick it off since
I'm the one that proposed this.
It's made sense for
quite some time
that just you two get together.
Half fitness reasons,
half purely selfish.
As a fan of what you've done,
us three write fairly well,
we've seen what you've done
behind the scenes
for a while now.
So I think for us it
makes sense to get together,
love to hear what you're up to.
- [Linds] Plus, we love Emma.
- I know.
- [Linds] I talk to
her about (inaudible).
- [Gary] Star of DailyVee 52.
- [Emma] Yeah, so
I worked with Peter before
I actually came to Vayner.
- [Gary] I know.
- And was working with Brooklyn
Bowl and then I came over to
Vayner and now I moved over
to on Peter's projects to do
marketing and yeah
I just think there's a lot of
partnership opportunities
between both of you.
Yeah, as Alex said, good
people for you both to know.
So, I think whether it's us
being able to connect you with
potent clients for VaynerTALENT
or us talking to you about what
we're looking to do with video
or our new platform fans
I just think there's a lot of
opportunities to
partner and chat.
- [Gary] I'm sure we're both
here for the same reason which
is, especially knowing what
I know about you from afar and
just knowing these people
so well and what they feel.
It's gonna be a game of the
other person trying to
provide value, right?
- [Peter] Yeah.
- From my standpoint, I'd love
to know the three most important
things for you in the world.
And I think, you
definitely know this,
and all of you know this,
if video's important to you,
I don't need you guys
to become a client.
If you want to come here,
or actually it's at 315,
actually, it's about to
be in Long Island City.
From my standpoint,
I'm just playing forever.
- [Peter] I play forever, too.
- You know what I mean?
And so for me, I have
zero short term wants.
Yes, I mean,
VaynerTALENT's super important.
So, we have a real thing that
were about to build so that's
good and cool but as far
as from your guys world,
any capability that
you guys want internally
I'm thrilled to lift the hood.
- [Peter] I have two
ideas, that's why I'm here.
- Okay. You gonna
figure out which--
- When do you have 'til?
- Probably the
Facebook video version
versus the CNN documentary.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
I don't know.
- [Alex] 40 minutes.
- 40? Oh great.
That's a lot.
That's a big one.
- So, I grew up
here in the city.
I wasn't so much a music guy.
I had a public access
TV show in high school.
- No shit.
- Yeah, channel 35.
- I love it.
- But it was on my
high school sports team.
I grew up, we did video.
- How old are you?
- I'm 44.
- Love it.
- Almost said 43.
- You just turned 44?
- Yeah.
- When?
- September.
- Oh, okay.
- I'm still saying 43.
- That's impressive.
- I'm November 14th and
I've already accepted
41 begrudgingly.
Go ahead.
You know what my LLC is called?
My personal LLC, the thing
I run everything through.
Filling The Seats.
- No shit.
- Because, now I'm gonna
tell you a story about Tribeca
because in 2005
Drew from Tribeca
Bar and Grill reaches out--
- I know him.
- And he goes,
"Hey, I hear you're like the
"new whiz kid of wine.
"We have this $200 wine dinner
"that we sold three seats for and
"I have to sell 190 of them.
Can you help?"
And I'm like,--
- Right.
- I'm like, "Me? Maybe."
I'm selling wine.
- Yeah.
- I'm a wine
retailer in New Jersey.
So, I send an email to
my wine email newsletter.
I have no idea what's gonna
happen and I get a phone call
from Tribeca Bar and Grill.
I sent the email 11,
I remember this like yesterday,
at 11:30 in the morning
at 12:17 they call me.
I get on the phone, they go,
"What the fuck did you do?"
And I said, "I sent an
email to my email newsletter."
They're like, "We've sold out.
"We've spent mailers,
"signage, calling people.
"You've sold out 140 seats."
I literally called my
accountant I'm like,
"I need you to register an
LLC called Filling The Seats."
That's why it's
Filling The Seats.
- [Peter] I know
things are starting.
- [Gary] Let's continue this.
Real pleasure.
Have a great, great holiday.
- Thank you.
- I'll try to see you
before the end of the year.
- [Emma] Thanks, Gary.
- Great to see you.
- [Tyler] Meeting got canceled.
- [Gary] Okay, good.
To where?
- [Tyler] (censored).
- Yeah. I'm gonna take this off.
Great day of hustle.
Got a lot done.
It was good to get back in the
grind after 10 days of filming
in LA and Thanksgiving weekend.
Really enjoying the
seven days a week DailyVee.
Hope you guys are as well
and I will see you soon.
(clicks tongue)
Deuce.